verschieden leicht einfach
Leute
es tut mir gut ich bin sieben Tage in
kompletter Dunkelheit sozial isoliert
und ohne Kontakt zur Außenwelt was für
viele wird das Schlimmste albtraumtönt
wird auch weniger Ort waldviert die
sogenannte
dunkelretreatsaboter
bis Wochen wo man sich alle visuelle
reizenziert das soll zur Tiefe selbst
Erkenntnis führen für mich ist eine der
tiefsten Erfahrungen die ich gemacht
habe so in meinem Leben
ich bin selber
was das mit einem macht sie warten
so was würde ich im Kino von dem eigenen
Lappen
[Musik]
crazy
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so 7 Tage dunkelretreat
let's go hat alles packt und
jetzt gehört sofort bezahlt vielleicht
Schweiz im nach Kloster wo man meistens
wucherlang sehr viel meditiert und er
mit der Rede das dunkle retrieb ist
quasi das einfach immer komplett dunkel
rum und ohne andere Leute
komplett frei vor allem unsere
Welt besser gesagt
möchte aber wissen ob das auch heikel
kann sie und Hannah Woche vorher der
Psychotherapeut Arnold Widmer tropfen
kann
psychische stabiler Mensch
vor allem auf dem Hintergrund dass man
das abbrechen
und regelmässig sie haben noch nie ein
Tagesstrukturen
produzieren das heißt sie warten
Halluzinationen
anmeldenformular geschickt die kann ich
mir so unterschrieben dass ich mich fit
genug fühle für sieben Tage Dunkelheit
und davor muss man sich da dass man drin
bleibt pflanzlich sind eigene Angst
aussetzt also ich würde wirklich jedem
empfehlen absolut nicht also man muss
wirklich
für mich kann man sowas Ziel gesetzt
haben
nach der halben
Corina
wo komplett abklappt worden ist mit
absolut kein Licht
leitet Corina sie zwei Jahre sowie
Schweiz zusammen mit ihrem Partner im
Fredi was würde sagen Grund
wieso blüht der
ja das ist ganz verschieden
viel waren da einfach mal ein auszieht
offline sie kein Handy und ein Rückzug
ist dunkles bis heilsames weißt du
Wirklichkeit Ablenkung
visuelle als wenn alles wegfällt
Schweiz sind will online Hanni nur knapp
60 dunkler wird
Schweizer
spirituelle Tradition bitte in indigene
Völker und bitte kälter und Druide ist
das wird Schwieger 2100 Franken für
insgesamt 9 übernachtet für das Geld
Kamera einfach das Licht ausschalten
aber dann wird nicht dreimal pro Tag für
dich kochen und der Betreuung auch nicht
mit dem Meister Lied wenn ich jetzt habe
ich immer Antworten
dabei das ist ja Horror nein das würde
ich nie machen das könnte ich nicht was
danke
sehr aktiven Gesellschaft sind wir sind
überhaupt nicht gewöhnt einmal inne
halten was machst du schon mal eine
Stunde ohne Handy oder also dass ich ja
wirklich das riesen Thema und
dann andere sieht es auch für wütend
einfach wirklich Angst vor der
Dunkelheit okay aber warum weil
irgendwelche Geschichten finde ich noch
wo man als Kind gehört hat mehr lief vom
Bösen weiß ich nicht wo sie der
Dunkelheit oder irgendwelche Angst sind
da nur mit der Dunkelheit verknüpft und
darum finde ich erschreckt weil
Dunkelheit ist eigentlich bis ganz
normal aber durch die massive Licht
Verschmutzungen
die wichtigsten Informationen für diese
Woche
zum Beispiel wie man wissen dass sie
essen vor dieses Zimmer gestellt hat
und
noch
und da seid Sie dass man jederzeit
und wirklich getrauer
schaffen damit die weitere teilnahmen
dass ich auf sich und der konzentrieren
Lichtschalter werden vom Freddy und der
Corina abklappt und schließlich können
wir nochmal im Kreis zusammen vor dass
man den einzelnen
okay
7 Tag
von dir zu
als erstes muss ich mich mal in der
dunkelheitsrecht finden und mir der Ruhm
anfangen merken
das ist mit Zimmer da und vermutlich war
mega hell und da irgendwohin
das ist alles Infrarot
Infrarotlicht drumherum
auf der Kamera hat so ganz
hinten auch so mit Schatten und man
denkt wirklich so ja es ist was du so
mega hell
es ist komplett dunkel
verbringt ich bin sehr müde und viel
gibt's wirklich nur
wir
spartenweise nicht
wie lange ich geschlafen
ganz ehrlich eigentlich so wirklich
scheiße
definitiv nur nichts Morgen zieht fürs
Assault bleiben also da dir ein Brüller
nach und Hotels
Zimmer ab
Essen gibt es zweimal am Tag am Morgen
und Mittag zusammen für morgen
Haferflocken mit Früchten
wie viel intensiver Dunkelheit wahrnehme
fahren
[Musik]
der größte Highlights vom Tag weil außer
essen
oder Sport machen das ist in der
Dunkelheit aber nicht so einfach
normale Sachen brauchen Zahnpasta
wenn ich irgendwo verloren bin versuche
mich anhand von der Matte zu orientieren
wo nichts mit dem Rum am Boden
und sie spricht auch schwierig zum
Vorstellen das soll
habe ich gesehen
die nur schwierig
immer so aufs nächste fixiert aber wenn
das nächste nicht mache ist ich hatte
trotzdem im Kopf dann Plan vor Orgas
nachts mache ich nicht und wenn dich
müde machen denke ich okay was möchte
okay dann bin ich am Handtasche so jetzt
hole ich gleich mal der techro und für
immer
okay okay Aktion gemacht was ich möchte
die Aktion
anstatt einfach mal
drei Aktionen machen
ich bin Laden
diese Witz
Fazit weniger machen morgen
es geht ja wirklich aufmachen
[Musik]
sind schon
mega mega
crazy pro Nacht Hanni wirklich so
zwischen 3 bis 5 träumen und alle fühlen
Sie sich über realistisch an
es geht immer wieder so Momente
so kleine Freude
Highlight vom zweiten Tag ich fahre
jetzt da nichts Mittag
und wenn ich mich mit Tische
da
kann ich es Picknick ein und zur
was ich glaube so viele Salzstreuer
einiges besser weil beim Meditieren
das ist genau das wo der Psychotherapeut
von uns gesagt hat
die Lichter begleitet mich auch der
folgenden Tag Tag 3 4 und 5
Tag kommt 200 Corinna verbieten
einfach täglich 12 14 Stunde
dunkelheitstage meistens im Link ist im
Stau ab und zu den Sport machen
meditieren oder atember
Dunkelheit ist es einfach auch still und
dir Stille wird alleine durchs
ankündigen vom Essen unterbrochen
ich wette 100
[Musik]
dem können
zwei Mal zieht
oft starker einfach solche im Zimmer um
und fühle mich dabei wir sondern
Spielfigur im Sims
unabhängig aber von der Tageszeit wird
ihn im Hopfen
Erinnerungen
okay ich mit 17 zack doch die ganze
Gefühl sagt etwas
[Musik]
Studium Basel die und dir vorlässige
dann friedlich morgen Aerobic und
Umstieg vorher am Abend im
ausgangssign Fußball
zack zack zack zack zack zack zack zack
Klarheit vor erinnere
alle nunnierka und jetzt würde ich
wissen
nie Vergangenheit so klar vor mir
gesehen dank mir wirklich einfach so hey
was
ist das Problem Robin was so viel
schöne gute
lustige Momente genau in der Moment wenn
ich in dem Moment wo ich
voll präsent sie wie das sind die Moment
wo mir etwas erinnere
die hunderte wenn ich sogar tausiger
Moment
klar dass ich mit der weniger schöner
Seite konfrontiert wird
sind so verschiedene
eigentlich für
so der kleine Robin müssen brüllen
und
sie schicken wir
in dem Moment gerade so kann ich das
sagen zeig mal ehrlich gesagt fast cool
mit dem schließen wenn ich nicht gerade
im Kino von meinem eigenen laber bin
sondern während dem Meditierer aktiven
nicht machen werde dir Farbe und Formen
in der ersten beiden Tag sie haben immer
intensiver das ist jetzt das Gefühl ich
bin
aber knurrt fest dass ich so merke okay
es ist schon
normal es ist auch völlig egal ob ich
Augen offen oder zur Hand während
[Musik]
am folgenden Tag erleben
ist schwer so als würde
so Dunkelheit Filme Platz Ina und mich
wieso aber drucken
hey nein
vorab bin ich gerade so auf dem Boden
schwieriger Tag danach Kamera
aufgestellt und deswegen einfach wieder
gut gegangen
hey was hä wie hat es sie und dann habe
ich gesagt
aufgestanden wie kann ich okay ja mir
ist wirklich so schwer kann ich mich
gefühlt denn eine logischerweise nur
schlechte gefühlsmäßig okay wirklich
schlecht und den eigentlich jeder
einzelne Gedanke hat auf das i zahl ich
will seine eigene Geschichte und ich mir
sieht am Morgen so verzählt anderes
wirklich so gemerkt hey es gibt so ein
Teil 1
selber verschafft du
Tisch so den Eignung Amboss eigentlich
so fühlt sich so
wie nur Tag sondern auch der Schlaf- und
Wachzustand vermischen sich immer mehr
so komme immer mehr in der Dunkelheit da
und kann wirklich aber fahre
[Musik]
alles
normalen
[Musik]
zum Essen zum Duschen zum Sport machen
einfach im Moment sie ohne irgendetwas
Bedürfnis ist so befreiend und durch das
schwappte große Ruhe und friedenheit
über mich alles fühlt sich einfach gut
an so wie es gerade ist mit dem Gefühl
in Erinnerung die letzten beiden Tag
aber wenn jetzt noch nie länger kein
Dinger bleibe kann ich schon bald
aussehen
krass glaube dass jetzt so sie betagt
nicht gemacht dass ich zu knurrt
Erkenntnis hobbing
für nachher wieder im Alltag also ja
t gefühlt oder Angst
kannst du mir jetzt überhaupt nicht gut
ich merke wenn ich jetzt wirklich so
viel nervös
und einfach mega aufgeregt wie um mich
also mega fest freue zum wieder Lied
gesehen
zum
Sprache zum Schlappen so Warner
ja
[Musik]
es ist so schön
dusse
landschaftsarzt gesehen und
es ist voll Winter
da und mit so viel Input wieder klar zu
überwältigend
nach mir haben wir dann alle anderen
wieder als Licht
am nächsten Tag können wir Natur zum die
Woche der Dunkelheit können
Moment sehr positive Erfahrungen
ist sogar drei Wochen drin das ist das
dritte dunkel retreat
ist eine der tiefsten Erfahrungen die
ich gemacht habe so in meinem Leben im
Moment fühle ich mich wirklich als wäre
ich wie
wie neu also das ist ganz ganz
interessant
und es ist so subtil es ist wirklich so
ein ganz zartes inneres Gefühl
noch insgesamt nie Tag der Opa ist sieht
nichts verabschiedet
die High fühle mich sehr ruhig und
zufrieden wird Jasmin das auch
beschrieben
von der Welt
was mich erstaunt ist wie empfindlich
ich auch Wochen später auf Tageslicht
bin ich muss weniger
Licht Dinge als Sonnenbrille
ist in der Ferien und den alten Folgen
der Woche versuche ihn möglichst die
Ruhe immer zu halten und meine
Handlungen bewusster zu machen zum
Beispiel kann ich ohne Handy und
Kopfhörer ist Jim dass ich kein ablenken
kann und so mich und mein Körper besser
wahrnehmen
für mich Schlussfazit jetzt habe ich mir
bewusst noch lieber einfach zum Lügen
wie das ganze auch nachhaltig auf mich
gewirkt hat weil gerade unmittelbar
nachher ist klar das sind so die
Erinnerungen die Halluzinationen sie
plus auch das Abtauchen in die
Vergangenheit wo wir so quasi Muster von
mir selber offenbartet jetzt aber über
einen Monat später würde ich sagen da so
jetzt nur am meisten bliebt ist das die
ganze Erfahrung Anker für mich ist und
ich mich im Alltag immer wieder Anruf
zurück besinnen das heißt wenn ich
möchte die verwirrt wenn ich viel
überlege jetzt viel weg mache danke
auf also es ist wieder das Werkzeug ihm
im Wahrzeichen eigentlich alles in allem
ist einfach extrem spannend die
Erfahrung sie und jetzt nimmt sich
natürlich wunderbar was haltet ihr davon
und auch würde dir auch bis zu trauen
unbedingt der ohne Kommentare und für
weitere Videos abonniere jetzt da der
Kanal